okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about features of Wolfram
language that are currently tagged as
experimental and which of them can be D
experimental eyes or what it will take
to make them not experimental and first
on our list for today is ask so ask has
not been as successful as I'd hoped
Carlo do you have a sense of why I think
that the problem is mainly that a bit
difficult to wrap your head around the
fact that you're really not not I mean
we only can simulate keeping state and
so you have to do all sorts of
contortions you have you have like very
domain-specific language for keeping
state across competitions having that's
awkward I mean what would we like to do
here the main point is ahead what this
was for was complex form filling
have we used it internally do we know
where have we used it I mean I mean some
people tried using it and I think that I
mean in the end the fact that you there
is also I mean there's a another problem
is a UX problem the fact that if you are
in a situation where you get one
question then the page loads and you get
another question then page loads you get
another question then that becomes
tiring soon and and people probably
prefer to see everything on a big screen
and some things are not compulsory
rather than you know loading things many
times well it depends on the complexity
of the forms I mean I kind of feel like
as we get form notebooks perhaps they
become I mean I I agree with you that
the the that you don't see it yet click
again to see the next page
I mean you know when you do surveys and
things online or whatever I mean there
are plenty of times when people do
segment the things and the multiple
pages and don't put everything on one
page true for that we have multi page
forms the question the only thing you
really can't do with multi page forms is
variable number of pages so if you know
that you're gonna have three pages you
can do it with multiple forms and
they're easier to write and easier to
interact with if you want like an
infinite loop of exercises then you
might want to use ask but it's not that
common right
I wish I could see a path forward here
too to understand you know how we make
this remember last time we talked about
this yarn was floating the idea of
having some kind of especially for I
mean if you also want an API version of
ask for of chatbots it's wrong to have
kind of to have these use a session
kernel instead of a public kernel so
that you don't need to do all this weird
stuff to keep state because your stay in
the same kernel mm-hmm so that might be
a path forward and think about that for
a second I mean so the chatbot case that
was the conversation page idea
yeah I mean I agree that using a session
Colonel was an interesting idea
essentially having an API that launches
a session colonel
um that's an interesting idea I mean
that would that would get rid of tons of
the complexity that's here
right yeah because on one hand we we
wouldn't be fixed to the tool to the
forms UX and on the other hand we
wouldn't be fixed to this the way but
what it basically is is it's just saying
from the web you're like you know it's
basically you got an API and inside the
API it's something that says essentially
start how would this work I mean you'd
say you know start session roughly and
then that would return a session ID so
your API no there'd be an API function
which contains start session okay then
what then how do you communicate how do
you return to that same session I think
you have to put something
can you do it with cookies probably do
it with cookies no but I mean I think
this is this going in wrong direction
like you you what ya know suggesting and
I probably don't want to talk too much
about it without him was to have some
kind of persistent persistent API
function sesh maybe I function I agree I
understand that I understand that but
one thing we should talk about I know is
that Christian is here and I remember
that when we lost talked about this
there was one of the requisites was try
and figure out what can stuff exists out
there in terms of web hooks and stuff
like that because it probably isn't an
API it's it's actually the other way
around
it's something that calls an API yes web
and so one thing we should really do
before we start designing this is like
yeah yeah King - all right so listen
let's let's branch this into an actual
meeting about essentially persistent
api's because I agree that that seems
useful okay weird echo here I mean if we
had something where I mean I think we
had a design at one point where the
thing gets back but there may be some
better way to do this because you have
to put code on the client side to you
know get back a token that you can use
to determine which session you go to
yeah making sense um because it's not a
browser session anymore the way
notebooks work is they attach to one
browser session yeah yeah I mean I don't
think that's that's very complicated
from technical standpoint I really think
we should on the other hand like someone
maybe who has worked on service connect
kind of stuff
look at how slack does it how you know
actually there's a very straightforward
way to do this the obvious way to do
this is that the client basically calls
the API function um with a UUID it
generates a UUID upon its first call
that UUID is then associated with that
session that's the right way to do it
yeah that's one way of doing it but
sometimes some systems want you to have
a key already when you start for example
and it's it's rate taking care of fine
fine okay well anyway look I think the
basic bottom line would ask is we're
gonna leave it experimental because it
hasn't really been working out and um
you know let's review this possibility
of doing persistent sessions maybe
that's we pivot this functionality into
that maybe we just decide this
functionality isn't that interesting I
mean I think you know it was it it was a
good idea but it hasn't worked out so
far but that's okay let's get a meeting
about persistent web you know persistent
api's okay makes sense to everybody
yes yeah you should be an that with Matt
yeah okay all right
on to the next thing then okay thank you
bye bye bye typesetting
so this is you know something we sort of
threw together for the channel stuff and
you know I'm not sure how robust it is
and you know we were sort of leading on
the channel stuff well do we have Jesse
or anybody else who is representing that
here they're supposed to be here but I
can try to grab Jesse Jesse here he's
not currently mom he's the one we'd need
I wasn't even aware this was handed off
from Egor to Jesse so yes okay but what
an F is this thing well right and yeah
I'm not convinced about this looks like
a complete mess
yeah what is it doing what's it for it's
how I see what's doing what the heck is
this doing it's basically trying to
serve to suppress format values so you
get you know most mostly input form all
right but so in this case here mm-hmm
okay fine now if I don't have that in
there
funky why is that funky no it's not
particularly funky it's just that that
as one of these cases where why hasn't
this come up before what happens if I
say input form of this yeah I get the
right thing so why isn't this input form
of a held object I guess speak well
that's yes more of a question for Igor
and I think it was a matter if they
wanted to return things that that would
be safe and so but that's such a losing
battle yeah
I was never a fan of this thing so
safe against what I mean right well I
get well I guess what happens if I have
a can I have an evaluation side effect
inside the formatting sure and is that
then not held by hold well it depends on
on how carefully it's written and what
it triggers but in principle right if
write a format value will fire whenever
even inside of hold so if it
that's scary why I mean well how else do
you expect things to format well I
understand I understand I mean if so if
I say format value of let's say a
correct form of format of I I never
write these you have X blank : equals
echo um you know echo X um hello
okay so now what you're telling me if I
say you of 78 whoops
you 78 it'll echo 78 and say hello all
right now I say hold this could be very
very very scary oh my gosh it's an
escapee it's not as ap you told it to
format under you told it to
unconditionally format you know no
matter what and so there should be in
the possible issue section of hold if it
doesn't already I think it is okay right
I mean this is the same reason why if
you do hold of graphics of disk you see
a disc a hold of a disc and not
something input forming
right yeah I understand so this is
another form of hold which is also
holding formatting well except it
doesn't have to hold attribute for for
some reason maybe I don't which I don't
recall off the top of my head so it
basically only has effect inside of
holding things well no I would imagine
that this what what that too right well
I think it evaluated away I mean do % /
/ full form or input form either way
right so it wants to effect formatting
but not evaluation so if it's stuck
around it would affect evaluation I
understand it is what it says here
call our livestream is saying something
about this put input form input form
what's he saying
confused by this oops
yeah well that's a known bug
what is that bug that the when you have
a single cell that generates multiple
texty form things I think it's multiple
text form things then only the last one
appears I mean I don't believe in this
happening inside a single cell anyway
this idea of multicellular output from a
single cell um it smacks of spontaneous
generation to me no I mean I'm being
celibate but you know it's always struck
me as being not a very desirable thing
to do right I tried to kill it
consistent right yeah I mean I agree
it's a bug in and it's inconsistent it's
just not a very easy bug to fix and you
know I think we'd need John to devote
some period of time to fixing it because
of course this this is a notebook thing
right if you like copied that and pasted
it into a raw terminal then that would
you know because the the second out
wouldn't be generated until the first in
was actually you know fully evaluated
[Music]
right so I didn't even yeah I can't do
it because right right and and and sort
of there are you know and and what's
particularly bad is I and I don't
remember which order it is but if one of
them was a wrapped in input form and one
of them was not and I don't remember
which is the order that generates this
then you would get the results in the
opposite order of what you wanted you
know Ethan is making the reasonable
comment on the live stream that this
could warn one that there's a lack of a
semicolon
you
because I think this idea of of
generating multiple output cells from a
single input cell is just a bad idea I
think it has all kinds of issues I've
tried to kill it multiple times over the
years does anybody want to claim that
it's a good thing it's like use the
cells I mean I will I will use it on
occasion so for example if I write if I
want you know generate several dynamic
things that will you know be tracking
evaluations below then I'll put all the
code for that in one cell and get my two
or three dynamical things as you know
all grouped together they're in
consecutive so your goal is to have
something I don't even know what the
grouping is in this case what is the
grouping in this case oh I see they're
all grouped with that input cell that's
interesting yes so that's sort of useful
right and then if I had just one of them
I really ate it and I regenerate all of
the outputs at once so I think that's a
separate thing okay so single input cell
you know what that really is you know in
an in a semantically cleaner situation
you know because if I put a parenthesis
it obviously wouldn't do this because
it'll be a multiplication then yeah uhm
you know in a semantically cleaner thing
there will be a kind of end of end of
input marker inside the cell that it
could for example automatically add here
if you understand what I'm saying so in
other words that instead of that being a
new line the the syntax cholera or
something could add something which
indicates that is a termination of input
and this is like having two cells
anyway this is something for the user
assistance meeting something we should
discuss I mean the thing that I could
imagine this doing maybe this is too
crazy is that this is a grouped input so
imagine that these were two cells but
they were pre grouped imagine that you
were in this situation where you have an
A and a B input cell okay and now I do
I group them okay now what happens if i
if i run this happened oh i see each one
made its own each one made its own
output it isn't it isn't that the
grouped input cells produced they could
have produced two grouped outputs but
they didn't right instead they rather
bizarrely they ungroup themselves and
then left didn't even make regroup well
I I mean that's arguably a bug but I
don't think it's as crazy as you think
it is because if you have automatic
grouping right and you have a section
cell and a bunch of inputs and then you
select that group and you evaluate it
and of course you want you know each
input to generate its own output and I
guess what happened here is because you
disabled automatic grouping when that
new cell was yeah broke things okay so
listen this is not the right meeting for
this but let us put this on the user
assistance agenda it won't be the top
thing unfortunately but but to discuss
essentially you know multi-part input um
yeah I mean I think multi-part input
whether it tries to indicate that it
thinks of this cuz you know if I put a
parenthesis there it will do that which
is very beautiful yep right that's a
really good piece of um you know user
assistance as far as I'm concerned so
the question is when does it you know
what it could do is it could ghost in
just like it's ghosting in that it could
ghost in a little return sign you know
um that's not what I wanted I wanted to
return indicator this one here it could
ghost in one of those at the end of the
line to indicate that it really is going
to treat it as a separate thing I'm not
sure I'd like to potentially suggest
that if we if somebody can come put that
on the user assistance agenda that would
be good if I can forward it okay so
listen disable formatting is not quite
as insane as I at first thought it was
even its name is not actually you know
utterly utterly insane I think um the
question of where it's used I mean wow
doesn't even mention the channel
framework here it will be good to hear I
don't know if Jessi joined us but it
will be good to hear okay do you know
anything about disable formatting on
whether we care about it yes I was
asking Igor about this just two days ago
because I encountered it and couldn't
really understand what it would it's for
it's a I'm not sure if you cover this
already but it's a it's a security thing
for the for the channel framework as far
as I know it was created for the channel
framework because there can be untrusted
expressions that come over come over the
wire and they get automatically wrapped
and hold complete unless there's
something simple like a string or an
integer anything more complex than that
or like a list of strings gets um it's
rather than the whole complete um but
that doesn't prevent yeah formatting
values from firing
this is this is a crazy thing this is
like you know there's a dyke it's sprung
a lot bunch of holes and you're plugging
different holes with with corks and
things you know this is just such a bad
idea right I mean the issue the issue
that I ran into actually that let me ask
her about it was that if you if if you
send a message that contains an image an
image expression and the message also
contains something else that's untrusted
like the Ross symbol it will wrap
disable formatting around the whole
thing and that causes the raw input form
of the image to print out as opposed to
the format it's crazy
look this is all just wrong I mean this
idea that you send stuff over and then
it you know it explodes on contact in
your and the client side it's just wrong
I mean the only way to solve this is to
have a sandbox in the client it seems to
me yeah but it would have to be a
sandbox of the of the front end because
the it'll it'll only print out with
stuff if you tell it to like if you put
echo as the as the the handler function
doesn't just do that by itself but if
you if you do in any way access either
tell it to print out messages come in or
access the message that comes through in
a way that it then it prints it out then
yet will it will get for me so let's
just let's be clear the problem case is
the client of the channel framework is
the front end and you are sending
through a thing that is I see it's it's
not even Auto evaluated it's even the
act of displaying it in the front end it
causes some evaluation to causes a
callback to the kernel which causes
evaluation to happen I will I wonder if
a way to do this might be to somehow
plug into the disabled format
sorry disable dynamic security thingy
right because right this is essentially
the reason why right dynamics work via
typesetting right and yes true right so
in a sense this is a similar problem so
maybe we
the conversation with E&H about what
does disable dynamic that's a that's a
that's right when you open a notebook
that's not from a trusted location right
and that you get the little yeah I know
right
but what is that is that an option or is
that a wrapper I I don't know how that
works so I think that's just built into
the notebook opening code in the front
I've heard that it can be applied on the
cell level there's a cell option okay
but that seems relevant to this as well
right so you're saying it I that so that
will be another approach insofar as what
is arriving on the channel framework is
going to be put into a cell you could
have that cell essentially have some
sandboxing in it like have the disable
dynamic disable formatting right thing
in the cell on the client side rather
than having the payload be somehow you
know wrapped in a notification stuff as
it comes over the wire I think it still
needs well one it's not wrapped as it
comes over the wire its wrapped at the
receiving end but I think it still needs
to be wrapped in something because the
channel framework has no way to affect
the options that get applied to to a
cell that its output it is he's a part
of since it there's no control over over
that that level of the process that
stage of the process like you could you
be doing whatever things you want before
it ends up in an outlet cell but it
still ends up in the nav itself
[Music]
well there were a disable dynamic rapper
that would that we were fine it would be
less less less complete than disable
formatting I don't know if that if that
solves the whole problem though if there
are any other if there any possible
exploits that beyond using dynamics pose
right so I guess the real question is
well yeah right I get it right the right
the issue is that in order for the user
to do something really harmful right
they'd have to send the format values to
be evaluated first right because
otherwise you know if they're just using
a standard system symbol right I
couldn't I can't guarantee that there's
no system symbol that has that has you
know that hasn't that doesn't evaluate
something as a side effect
I don't know between template boxes and
all those kinds of things I'm not
certain that's the case the way question
of Lily well I'll think about that but I
think you'd have to be I mean there are
certainly plenty of carelessly writtens
format values which sort of leak the
contents of I guess that is the danger
that they're carelessly written format
values that evaluate the contents during
formatting and so you could have you
know what about what about compressed
data how is that handled in the front
end because that can be part of a cell
expression and it gets at some point
evaluated I think by the front end yeah
I don't think it's evaluation I took
it's just decompression right it just
deserialized without evaluation and um
we got a couple of questions on the live
stream here from Nicola disabled for
hunting is talking about sunning
graphics through a socket without losing
the content of it I don't fully
understand why you would lose the
content from the thing going through a
socket Jessie maybe you know the answer
to that
well as long as it's properly serialized
which is really any kind of
serialization input form or or like
binary serialized should it should be
fine like graphics can definitely be
safely not serialized so I don't fully
understand that um Ethan is saying it's
giving an example here of using let's
look at his example um standard form
okay that's a different function I mean
so you're defining hold formatting and
then
which is it different than that's
disabled formatting without the
requirement that the inside a holder
hole complete yeah yes it's yet another
form of holding that is both the holdall
and a format holder boy right but the
point is if you do again percent / input
form then you'll see the old formatting
the whole form yeah it'll be there
exactly which is precisely why we didn't
like we wanted it to evaporate away what
a mess well okay look in 30 years this
disable forwarding thing has been
surprisingly non used I mean no I mean
no we've had it for very long but but
this issue with the general framework of
you know sort of things that are explode
on on delivery
I think it's an insoluble problem and I
think that it's I mean gosh II never do
this I mean you you never get sent this
is like you know you send something to a
web browser and then the web browser
goes and you know runs raw code which of
course it doesn't I mean that's the you
know one of the main features of web
browsers that people make use of is the
fact that they're sandbox in various
ways and our front end was never
intended to be a sandboxed recipient of
content
but now we're trying to make it like
that Jessie am I missing something here
I mean just seems like a super bad idea
well what what exactly is that idea why
do we want the channel framework to be
able to deliver things that explode on
contact so to speak that they do it
delivers something into the client that
automatically does evaluation on the
client side well it's not explicitly
desired but it's it's just a byproduct
of the fact that we can send any
expression over no you're right
yeah not being able to format it it's
kind of a big downer yeah like I would
be satisfied if there were like a
variant of disable because the only
problem I have with disable formatting
is the one that I just encountered which
is that it causes like there are
scenarios in which it can cause things
that really should be formatted like
images that are I can't imagine how an
image expression could possibly be
unsafe to format but who knows but it
can cause things like that to or will
cause things like that to to not be
formatted so there were a variant of
disable formatting that um disables
formatting on everything except
obviously safe expressions then then
that would be fine or actually the the
thing was that it affects how the front
ends automatic collision happens like
even even if you did input form but not
input for him but um like well north
normally normally something like am yes
got it look here's a question one thing
that you know is never come up to my
knowledge which we now need to
understand is what are the side effects
and formatting okay what actually
happens in Voynich because there's
certain kinds of evaluation that are
really not problematic you know adding
numbers is not going to be problematic
um
arguably and this is something for Raj
we should run some test Suites where we
try and pick up you know what is
happening in different kinds of
formatting what evaluation is actually
going on which I don't think we know did
that make sense
you know it's what Colonel calls are
made during what Colonel callbacks
occurred you're in formatting do we
think we know that I mean it would be
hard to track down all the tests which
which are formatting related and then
you know I mean if we kept it on like
all our tests which is about seven
hundred thousand without picking and
choosing then it's you know I can
declare but I mean well first of all I
mean formatting in the what form right
because things were forum format
differently and likely have different
evaluations in different output forms
that's arbitrary evaluation right and
people you know may make use of that I
don't necessarily approve of this but
right people want their fancy dynamics
thing so they have looked okay don't we
have a sandbox that deals that we use in
the cloud for example that deals with
not being able to access the file system
and so on
yes why can't we run that sandbox during
formatting because it's a one-way street
what does that mean you can turn it on
but you can't turn it off no I
understand but I'm saying
during formatting this thing that jesse
is doing when we is sending stuff
through the channel framework and then
you know I'm asking could one set it up
so that
the evaluation that's done at what is
supposed to be formatting time is
sandboxed
by that sound box
what would it do to dynamics sandbox
them through the entire duration of the
output cells existence this is a
complicated problem right and and for
example if you have you know file or URL
which have these little open buttons
attached to them right that's in
principle evaluation that's happening
during formatting I guess post
formatting but right it's a sort of
formatting it's it's not obvious this is
actually what we want this is a
complicated problem we're not solving it
here and it's disabled formatting is
some small tentacle of this whole
horrible thing by the way b3 in our live
stream is talking about malicious code
jumping from one API to another I'm
happy to say that that will be firmly
impossible very soon because we are
about to have forked kernels that will
be completely separate kernels for
running different API calls so um we're
not recycling them all right let's have
a quick look here oh boy um can I let's
just look at network programming for a
second because Jesse would be a good
person to be part of this um
who's representing network programming
here
TARDIS interior let me just go get him
okay wait a minute there's a bunch of
stuff here with sockets Oh sigh Jessie
have you been using the socket stuff do
you know about the socket stuff lately I
use it a little bit for something not
related to general favor okay
come on give me something that's ready
to do experimental eyes no these are all
you know the last set of failures which
are all you know recommended to be kept
experimental so Bobby this live yes I
mean you're looking at the bottom of the
barrel right now but well I don't think
these are the bottom of the barrel I
don't think these should be kept
experimental these things seem to me to
be real and very reasonable okay Devon
can you get Constantine yes okay okay
Nikola on livestream is asking an
interesting question come on run the
wolf mansion locally in sandbox mode
that should be something that we should
make possible
man I mean it's just a command-line
option well except I remember advice but
I mean it exists yeah I mean how do you
not how do you think it's activated on
the on the servers oh it's certainly not
documented because I wrote that
documentation and I never heard of it
you did not write this documentation
when the the Wolfram script
documentation well I'm not talking about
the Wolfram script documentation because
we're talking [ __ ] an option to
Wolfram script it's not into Wolfram
okay and and certainly even the Wolfram
script documentation has evolved
significantly since your initial draft
okay all right okay um fine I'm always
glad to know that I don't know what I'm
talking about but it's which may be the
case in this right I I'm just saying I
don't want the many many hours I spent
with Garret improving the Wolfram
scripts page to be ignited okay well I'm
glad you did okay it's not documented
but I think there isn't the problem and
just what is it cold it's I believe it's
- sandbox so that would become a Wolfram
script option sure
if she loves yeah I mean so being the
execution options mm-hmm seems
reasonable to me are there options to
how its sandbox what level of sandboxing
is it just um it's a it's a it's an it's
a boolean as far as I recall sure
probably seems boxed past possible yeah
go ahead it seems to work with Wolfram
script - it seems to get passed through
to Wolfram well pass any options it
doesn't recognize okay Bernal okay so
the answer for Nicola is yes you just
say - sandbox is that correct
that correct
that well that's what you do to sandbox
stuff yes Jesse did you confirm that
that it's a sandbox
yes it's - sandbox I think it should be
- sandbox shouldn't it but I don't think
so I think can options are generally
like present tense active okay fair
enough right like - print alright fair
enough
Stephen Todd is here okay alright we're
talking about two things we're talking
about network programming and were then
talking about scheduled tasks what a
control I'm sorry I'm should be looking
ahead here um
the um okay network programming so we
got two very different kinds of things
Network packet trace and so on why
are these I mean I these are a little
bit squiggly because they depend on
system features which are not always
present is that correct correct yes and
even if they're present you may need to
manually adjust permissions to and is
that is that a an increasing or
decreasing problem that is the ability
to capture the stuff is it something
that OS manufacturers are progressively
closing down or progressively opening up
or they've never noticed the issue or
what what's the story hey I think it's
pretty stable I mean they yeah I mean
the need for pcap on Windows for example
I think that's been around for years and
years and years and so we able to
install that or do we need you need
admin privileges to install it well you
did that's what system isn't that's one
of the things that system installers for
right and it just installs it and but
with on on UNIX right the permissions to
these devices is off by default and you
need to enable reading permissions I see
or run as root or some other privileged
user we should talk about that
separately but that's it that's a more
complicated thing okay but things like
the socket listening stuff why is that
being kept experimental that seems like
it's you know it's been around for a
while why is it not ready for primetime
Todd yeah I'm trying to I'm trying to
recall our discussions about this well
and part of relevant developers is no
longer with us
I for example the changes were made in
12.1 to some of this functionality so
for 12.1 at least it was good that this
stuff had been marked experimental so I
may be full
city of if you made some changes to
things from one version to the next it
should be experimental for that bird no
that's not correct well that was a much
too strong a statement okay but but
listen why don't we do this with the
socket stuff why don't you go find out
what the issues are with socket stuff
because you don't know and there's no
much point in a speculating here I have
to okay fine
all right so we're just not ready for
that okay edge will tasks what is wrong
with scheduled tasks why are we not do
experimental izing all the scheduled
tasks stuff it seems to work just fine
to me I think I think I could produce
counter examples to that statement but
Constantin is probably in a better
position yeah I I ran into seven bucks
it bit scary okay but bugs are not the
same thing as keeping the things
experimental one thing that is needed is
a way to initialize the variables if you
run the task on the rim on a separate
kernel or probably in the cloud as well
you don't think about that before okay
so hold on hold on hold on the question
here is is this framework but for bugs
something that we think is stable
because I think the answer is yes this
baby ball yes yes so I'll give you two
things that I've found a problem so I've
been doing parallel stuff recently and
if I try and do a generate document with
a notebook run the notebook template
system that requires says it needs a
front end if I say using front end it
then hangs in the parallel kernels
that's one thing the other thing I just
found yesterday is a problem with the
resource system with parallel Colonels
some failure to be thread safe in the
way resources resource functions are are
retrieved so and that's why Raj I'm
asking you to try and run our tests
within you know parallel sub Colonels
right many of those there are yes
similarly that is on my list
okay so similarly we should be running
the tests in submitted tasks so what I'm
saying because I have no idea what weird
things could happen in a session
submitted tasks for example I can I can
imagine you want me to start inventing
bugs I bet session time is really messed
up in a session submitted task for
instance no it is most most used as far
as they see it's what people keep asking
about session submit so people are when
they try to use it and I think it's
mostly used so you say it basically
works but why are they asking about it
there is a misconception of what can be
done in a task for example missed your
cell phone so it's not of fully threaded
application it's a pre-emptive tasks and
sometimes that gets in the way well we
like like what
so I mean you're explaining to me things
that should be in the documentation and
so on about what can't be done or should
be messaged in some way what does it do
when it can't do something like for
example could I run the document
generator in sessions in the session
tasks I bet I couldn't because I bet
that would require re-entrance
in re-entrance e in front-end code that
isn't there
I expect that would work Steven I don't
ever tried it I mean I think the real
issue with session submit is if you try
something that takes a really long time
and you know you your colonel gets
preempted and it can't be a long time
and you you can't priam preemption and
so you just stop there waiting for it to
finish and maybe you don't even know
what's happening because the colonel is
just not doing anything your to your eye
okay
sorry people try to use session submit
in that dynamic code and since from
under the cover they use the same
mechanism so that it work on what
messages disappear in either dot does
not update and kill the dynamically
finishes or it does dynamic doesn't
update if I kill the task she does it
know what's going on could it give a
message or is it so
so preempted by the pre-emptive so to
speak they can't even get a message out
you cannot get the message out so it's
basically something that needs to be
clarified in the commutation at least
because pre-emptive evaluation we
mentioned only in one place which is
unrelated to tasks and okay but so with
local submit and the initialization
stuff um so in loco submit you can for
example you send some cold to be related
on their on the support Colonel but you
need to initialize to initialize the
variables are not Colonel first you
cannot do that within the task so the
need of making is really you could if
you want to say x equals zero you say x
equals zero semicolon rest of tasks I
mean it's one thing
you want to persistently initialize and
have the thing you know but but this is
starting a new separate kernel isn't it
yes so who cares whether the initial I
mean it might be compete for your
packaging to do the initialization first
go ahead yes so in second usage you see
that look awesome Ito schedule tasks so
if you prepared some expression if you
put some expression before scheduled
tasks it will not work because it if you
want to work if you want this to work
then we'll have to look at scheduled
tasks anywhere in expression that others
passed I'm sorry would you say well what
did you say said it again good so you
can put X equal to zero and then
semicolon scheduled tasks but that's not
supported because to support this fully
we have to we will have to detect
expression I don't send this is within a
local submit you have a submit first
argument yes you give a scheduled task
yes you cannot prepared anything right
now I get whistling yeah I understand
what you're saying what you're saying is
that in this case you can't do what why
aren't you putting the initialization
into the expert of the scheduled tasks
no because it's all yet it won't be
evaluated every time so it will
essentially reset so but your energy is
once you could do that yes I don't think
once existed before but I don't even
understand if it's the same kernel
that's running all the separate
scheduled tasks why would it be just
goes to sleep between the scheduled
tasks even if it's a year between
scheduled tasks it does yeah it doesn't
restart a new kernel no it's the same
kernel do we have an initialization
option that we could provide from it I
mean it might be easier for somewhere
else like I'm dynamics that is we have
some option like that elsewhere right
manipulate has I think it
initialization yeah so we could
certainly put that into local submit but
that does not prevent us the
experimental izing these things that's a
detail both the things you've instrument
are important things to put in I mean I
don't see any objection I think this
things are working just fine
okay yeah so well we'll put that the
mercy option actually what one Ethan is
saying tasks don't work with both local
and cloud tasks Tosca open/close really
they see I may not have any running oh
okay this what the heck is this
apparently it's some tasks you have
created on the cloud right and since
you're currently in that 12 1 or 12 - no
no that's ok
no that's correct ok let me point out
another bug see that 12 it's not offset
from the line of the message some does
some glitch there ROG that's for you I
think did you do that yep got it but
wait I just saw a pull request that had
split up the functionality of tasks so
the tasks with no arguments did not
return cloud tasks you had to say tasks
of all to see local end cloud we talked
about that last time on this meeting
because tasks from nautically LCC but
although she she that's fascinating I
went to that task seems to be reject
what said I like a page surrounding
since March
well Tony executed twice task name
doesn't seem to what is this dollar task
configuration of name I've never seen
this what is this thing
this is the page that Dylan was building
but I don't think I have a sword why is
that GMT minus five smooshed together
like that this is very weird what is
this is this is this the time and what
is time spec okay guys this page has
never been reviewed maybe this is new in
12:1 I don't know wow do you know
anything about this about the page or
yes about the page about the existence
of now well it's quite lovely except
it's never been seen by any of us could
we get this reviewed and kind of find
out how come it didn't ever get reviewed
okay Todd is this in your area or is
this somebody else's oh no this is a
cloud okay then let's get it in the
cloud meeting we have one tomorrow I
think or the next day
apparently so but it's only executed
twice how come oh because look it only
ran it isn't it this is very unclear
this this task is over right no end date
is at the end of days so to speak in in
summer yes so that time spec don't
belong already for I want it says status
finished so but it isn't it's got an end
date of of forever well I think or they
think you probably gave it account right
because there's no a sequence indefinite
there's no count in the time spec okay
so listen this is unclear this page has
never been reviewed the pages looks kind
of beautiful except that it's someone
unclear what it's talking about so let's
get this page reviewed it's probably
gonna need a separate meeting just to go
over this page and in this particular
case we're totally mystified about
what's going on here yep totally
mystified okay but that does not affect
us the experimental eyes in all of this
task stuff so we need to revisit tasks
because it should report Clawd tasks and
local tasks separately and there is a
poor request on that
how is it going to do that it's going to
have an association no you just say our
tasks gives you local and tasks of cloud
gives you cloud objects because it's
from preach to the cloud if you do
something locally it's wrong 15 we went
through all this last week you don't now
you have a pull request and we'll update
the documentation okay the experiments
why is it yes so I think yeah so this
and the unionization installation option
so - that's reasonable
okay and yeah I think otherwise these
can be DX paralyzed by the way I can't
imagine why URL downloads submit has to
be experimental why not but okay so I
see no reason to think that this has to
be experimental okay we are
unfortunately over time so it probably
what was that what was the issue of the
blockchain pages so I updated all the
pages Brian and you requested and
they're wishing the thing is I think
this week I've never gotten an answer to
why the usual model of having one page
per symbol and one page per you know
type doesn't work why do we need because
these pages are unfortunately in detail
interwoven in a messy way in other words
blockchain block data is bizarrely
different between Bitcoin and aetherium
and to weave them both together on the
same page it's just super confusing
right wait so in other words this is
branching the thing because any given
person only cares about the Bitcoin one
or only cares about the etherium one
they're not really interested in
comparative literature of block chains
most of the time um and you know so
that's why we tried to branch them like
this I don't think it's the best
solution and when we have many more
block chains we'll probably want to
refactor this somehow but I think so far
it's a it's a decent way of handling I
mean we expect a bunch more block chains
fairly in fairly short order right I
like it's it's good how we have a page
for each block chain I'm still not happy
with how discoverable they are but yeah
it's it's nice right but I mean but also
will presumably have particularly with
these non you know with these slightly
more more custom block chains we will
presumably have a landing page arc
probably has their own landing page and
we probably have a landing page for them
which will be probably the place where
people will get to the documentation
about the arc block chain um in our
ecosystem right so for now we have a
guide page for each of the merchants
I understand which is fine as a landing
page but I'm thinking that they'll be
essentially a marketing landing page for
these block chains maybe even for these
ones as well but these are less clearly
you know their ecosystem is not such
that people are going to point people
from their ecosystem to our pages that
make sense because there isn't a
centralized place for these you know
we're talking about the centralization
of decentralized technologies here um
all right since we've only got one more
thing left I think we should just have a
quick look at it do you have any
question about the
experimental status of the blockchain
symbols which blockchain symbols I mean
what what which thing is experimental
everything I mean where's whistle oh I
think we should probably leave it that
way because the fact is I can continue
to think blockchain is an emerging area
I don't think anybody's going to be
upset by those things being experimental
I know it's not like go ahead I will
need to see for this I need flexible
enough to when we add more blockchain so
art is the first blockchain we are that
is different from yeah I think it's fine
to leave a blockchain stuff experimental
okay let's just tackle one last thing
whatever this is form control
this is all this was a weird refactoring
where even you know form control oh I
see this is a dynamic in the style of
slider of dynamic of X version I am so
confused of form right right it was an
attempt to bind a form to a variable the
same way that slider binds a slider to a
variable okay um what do you make of all
of this I mean in other words don't we
have the mechanism with form function
open clothes or that but that doesn't do
the same binding thing that does a a
fill it out submit it and it returns
into the notebook right it doesn't do
the binding at all the point of this was
to build out something that could be
used simply and manipulate and our best
thinking a few months ago when Carlo and
I last met about this was to build
rather than build out support for full
forms to start by building out support
for a flavor of input field that would
be able to take arbitrary interpreters
as the target for that input I say makes
good sense so I mean so field at a time
basically rather than friend correct and
that's just waiting for me to have some
time to look at that there's the there's
the very scant beginnings of it in the
prototype build but I don't know that
that's worth looking at okay
well it's an interesting direction I
mean I think it relates to form
notebooks as well because imagine a form
notebook right imagine a form notebook
where you want to have something which
looks like a form right you could have a
form function in a form notebook but
this may be a better way to do it which
I hadn't really thought about
right and I suppose another question is
what if we want one of these new input
fields that have yet to be designed in a
form so we'll have to figure out how to
cross pollinate these yeah but I think
the most immediate thing um you know
somebody is actually actively working on
form notebooks it probably worth
pointing out to its Stephen children and
Andres group who's doing this um just
point out this form control thing to him
okay
I have a meeting with him tomorrow about
four notebooks so I can good hopefully
form notebooks coming along well I'm
looking forward to seeing more of them
all right
well we managed to make it through the
agenda so true statement a question
about the network programming stuff
which we kind of skipped do you want
that to be discussed in this series or
will that be discussed outside of the
series because we're done here the
network well I mean we've got sockets
and we've got this network programming
stuff right because the last off off the
ceilings like a fear if you want to
discuss it outside of the meeting you
know we have gone wrong maybe we can
okay is there stuff that we should be
recycling through this meeting where we
said let's put that back for further
discussion or we really really done that
really all experimental functionality
we've gone through in these meetings I
mean the Venter almost 600 plus pages so
across 13 meetings all right
seems like less than that I appreciate
that okay um I'm surprised that these
meetings can end I have to tell you um
but um let's see I mean end for this
version again we'll we'll have to take a
look at it again for the next version
right well there's nothing more to say
about the network stuff for this version
so there's no reason to talk about that
the socket stuff Todd maybe we can put
that in the ECE meeting
if there's something to say about it I
mean you said you were gonna go figure
out what was happening with the socket
stuff yeah
yes meaning that's a great place to do
that okay fine all right
good stuff right that's it again good
thanks